[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we know Donald Trump jr.
confessed to at least trying to conspire
with a Kremlin linked lawyer two weeks
into the presidential general election
campaign in hopes of getting dirt on
Hillary Clinton but lost in the
now-standard maelstrom of our lives is
the stunning reality that Donald Trump's
senior also all but confessed to trying
to conspire with Vladimir Putin to clear
the path by which the Russians can come
back and attack our midterm elections
next year and our presidential election
in 2020 mine are just interpretations
not legal opinions but I'm right and the
intelligence services of this country
and probably the world keep dropping
quarters into the slot-machine one
quarter at a time hoping this quarter
will be the one that produces the story
that awakens the nation to the
disloyalty and perfidy of the president
and his mafia like family and which
awakens his Republican enablers to the
danger the Trump gang represents to
their own re-election bids the elder
Trump's confession was so damaging he
actually tried to walk it back his
actions are not those of anyone let
alone anyone in power whose loyalty is
to the United States of America indeed
his actions seem more like those of
someone whose loyalty is to the Russian
state 7:50 a.m. July 9th Putin and I
discussed forming an impenetrable
cybersecurity units so that election
hacking and many other negative things
will be guarded that is a confession to
responding to the worst sneak attack
against this country since 9/11 or even
Pearl Harbor by discussing the
possibility of sharing our cybersecurity
operations sharing our intelligence
sharing our defenses with our enemy
after our enemy interfered with our
elections last year in advance of the
elections of 2018 and 2020 Trump's
so-called election integrity commission
is still trying to get the same types of
voter registration data from each state
that the Russians were reportedly
searching for when they hacked into
those state computers last year put
these stories together and you can see
warnings that Trump may be planning to
consoie
with Russia about the next elections
evidently even Trump realized this 8:45
p.m. July 9th the fact that President
Putin and I discussed a cybersecurity
unit doesn't mean I think it can happen
it can't we had never seen Donald Trump
truly scared before we have now scared
enough to back away from an agreement
that might have been treasonous he may
have been scared as much by his son's
tone-deaf confession as by his own
junior first denied ever meeting with
any Russians during the campaign then
caught hosting a Kremlin length legal
thug and Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort
on June 9th 2016 he said it was a
throwaway meeting about Americans
adopting Russian children then something
else came to light they could the Intel
guys and the slot machine they had a lot
of quarters something else happened and
Trump jr. changed to a third story I was
asked to have a meeting with an
individual who I was told might have
information helpful to the campaign this
is a meeting he has denied having a
meeting he apparently has lied about for
at least five months so to Kushner so to
man afford the woman stated that she had
information that individuals connected
to Russia were funding the Democratic
National Committee and supporting Ms
Clinton instead of throwing this
individual out of the building or his
Nixon Attorney General John Mitchell
said about gordon Liddy during Watergate
out of the window he and Kushner and
manna fort met with her for 20 to 30
minutes no details or supporting
information was provided or even offered
it quickly became clear that she had no
meaningful information
she then changed subjects that was
juniors problem with the Kremlin
connected lawyer not that she was a
foreign lawyer reportedly trying to pass
him and Kushner and manna Ford and the
Trump campaign damning information in
hopes of nefariously influencing the
outcome of an American election his
problem was that she wasn't passing him
damning information in hopes of
nefariously influencing the outcome
an election or at least that's what he
claims and not incidentally nobody is
explaining three pieces of timing in
this jr. Kushner and the Russia friendly
man afford meet with the Russian lawyer
June 9 mana fort becomes Trump's new
campaign manager June 20 an Associated
Press story that places Trump senior in
Trump Tower for nearly all the day the
meeting took place and the fact we have
already noted here that on June 9 at
4:40 p.m. presumably after that meeting
truck tweets for the first time about
Hillary Clinton's 33,000 emails that you
deleted while Trump senior was at the
g20 summit again denying the
incontrovertible fact that our
intelligence agencies are confident they
have firm evidence the Russians
interfered with our elections last year
like meeting with Trump's son Trump's
son-in-law and Trump's soon-to-be
campaign manager in Trump Tower 13
months ago while Trump was again
reportedly accepting the meaningless
denials from a murderous dictator and
pledging to quote move forward and
working constructively with Russia while
Trump was proposing or listening to
Putin's proposal for this joint
cybersecurity let the Russian Fox Guard
the American n house deal while Trump
fiddled for Putin's pleasure news broke
that our nuclear power and energy
related computer networks were burned
hacked and all initial evidence shows
this was done by Russia again and this
this darkest most cynical most disloyal
most evil action ever committed by any
president or significant leader in our
nation's history this atrocity Trump has
somehow managed to escalate even this to
something worse Trump is literally
virtually simultaneously accepting the
claim that the Russians did not
interfere with the election last year
while saying that President Obama was
derelict in his duties for not punishing
Russia for what Trump thinks Russia did
not do in his criminality escalated to
madness
Trump has now done everything except to
ask Vladimir Putin to clear and publicly
Sunday morning Trump's first campaign
manager mr. Lewandowski said he knows
that the Russians
not violate our election because
Vladimir Putin says so
Trump quoting Lewandowski pressed him
very tough to find out if Russia had
anything to do with the outcome of the
u.s. election and from what Vladimir
Putin has said the answer is no so now I
think the issue is officially dead like
so many of Putin's opponents and happily
after this cascade of criminally stupid
confessions by two different men named
Donald Trump officially dead like the
long term prospects for the survival of
this presidency resist remove peace